cette semaine rendent au pays vous
propose de découvrir la coulée de 2004
aux grands brûlés et la magie de ces
tunnels de lave
rendez vous aux grands brûlés dans le
sud sauvage où se succèdent les
dernières coulées majeur de la fournaise
c'est celle de 2004 qui a en partie
recouvert celle de 2001 que nous vous
proposons de découvrir aujourd'hui par
an dessus et en dessous
quand suffisamment refroidi et
stabiliser la coulée possède en effet un
réseau de 6 km 5 de tunnels de lave que
l'on peut explorer
pour cela comme en spéléologie il faut
prévoir un équipement spécifique et
c'est vincent cheville accompagnateurs
en montagne qui nous emmène
la fournaise est un volcan de type
hawaïen aux éruptions effusive canton
progrès sur la coulée on y retrouve donc
les formes caractéristiques de ce type
de vols temps comme les grattons et
surtout les laves cordée qui
correspondent à des plissements de la
lawe dû à son refroidissement au contact
de l'air
marché sur ses coups les dix ans après
l'éruption permet aussi d'observer la
recolonisation des espèces végétales en
une dizaine d'années on voit que la
colonisation est quand même assez rapide
alors tout commence suivant les
altitudes il se trouve dans le bord de
mer parlez à l'apparition daeniken qui
vont avoir plus de facilité à reprendre
sur le gratton et après donc on a toutes
les autres espèces qui arrive le lichen
ayant un peu détériorée la roche donc
les fougères qui vont mourir faire un
peu du musée permettre au bois de
chapelet de s'installer au petit bois de
remparts et enfin espèces que vous nous
attriste par excellence le fida très
intéressant pour retenir et sol dans les
cirques et à la plage par exemple
malheureusement ici ça nous sert pas à
grand chose en fait ils vont coloniser
entièrement la coue faire de l'ombre à
toutes les espèces endémiques
réunionnaise qui malheureusement ont une
croissance bien plus lentes et du coup à
terme dans cette zone du grand brûlé
quand ils les auront détruit toutes les
espèces endémiques on aura plus du
filament l'exploration souterraine peut
commencer plusieurs entrées
correspondant à des effondrements
permettent d'accéder au réseau de
tunnels celle ci est moins utilisé par
les guides mais elle permet de découvrir
une salle aux couleurs unique baptisé le
salon rouge
c'est en fait une pièce où le plafond le
sol tout est rouge
une grosse différence sur cette salle
c'est qu'on est proche d'une fissure qui
restait ouverte en grosse partie de
l'éruption et du coup il y avait un
apport d'oxygène à cet endroit là et
l'adaf du coup à chauffer refroidi très
lentement avec cet apport d'oxygène le
faire présence est oxydé ce qui donne
cette couleur à bourges on est vite
devenir en encadrement elle est un peu
excentré par rapport aux autres belles
galeries on peut retrouver du coup on
n'y vient pas et c'est aussi dans un
dans une volonté de protection
marché dans les entrailles de la coulée
offre des sensations uniques
un spectacle de couleurs et de formes
dont la plupart expriment les mouvements
de la vie on peut parfois observer des
tunnels en miniature qui permettent
aussi de comprendre comment se sont
formées ceux dans lesquels on évolue
ça correspond aux dernières lave qui ont
coulé et qui se sont figés l'a donc
modèles réduits de du grand tunnel qu'on
a autour vous avez la lave qui descend à
l'inférieur et on voit que du coup des
bords de la rivière se resserre de plus
en plus ils vont arriver jusqu'à former
autour le stade de formation c'est
d'abord les bords de la rivière au
refroidissement qui se fait par un
extérieur la lave coule elle charrie à
l'intérieur
plein de petites roches ont imaginé ces
roches qui descend dans la lave en
fusion qui vont venir se coller sur les
côtés la force des deux parois se
rapproche et finissent par certains
certains trous parfaitement formés sont
des péris morphose ou baril qui
correspondent aux troncs d'arbres pris
dans la lave qui se sont consumés
lentement d'autres formes sont de
petites salades mythe de l'avs au
plafond les stalactites qui tombent sont
parfois de couleur différente ce qui
fait la beauté de ces tunnels vous avez
vu le plafond est pas très haut et du
coup en fait là vous imaginez un tour en
commun turandot dû coûter car sa
rencontre un obstacle ou des quelque
chose tombe dedans ça éclabousse et ça
va vous faire cette couleur gris
métallisé vous pourrez apparenté à une
sorte d temps donc ça c'est toutes les
projections l'autre à côté c'est autre
chose c'est tout simplement que pour
former deux tunnels il a fallu que la
lame soit au plafond au début le niveau
progressivement est descendu remontée
redescendu pour imaginer un plafond
plein de lave en fusion comme de la cire
qui est chauffée par cette lave qui
passent en dessous et à l'intérieur de
ce basalte on a pas mal de silice donc
la silice quand on va fait choper ça
nous donne du verre et dans fait c'est
comme une pâture aux vitrifiés et ça
prend des couleurs plutôt chocolat ou
bronze l'activité de découvert des
tunnels de lave est en plein essor sur
notre île et les dernières coulées
réserve encore bien des surprises tant
qu'elles ne seront pas recouverte par de
nouvelles éruptions
ce que j'aime dans ces tunnels c'est
déjà la bouteille au niveau visuel et
puis après c'est de se retrouver dans
les entrailles du volcan être marcher
dessus c'est une chose être dessous c'en
est une complètement différente on a
beau être enfermé pour moi c'est une
sensation de bien-être vous êtes coupé
de tout on perd complètement la notion
du temps dans l'obscurité et du coup on
peut y passer des heures et des heures
sans se rendre compte que c'est déjà la
fin de la journée ces tunnels de lave
sont ouverts au public
néanmoins il ya des risques propres à
liés à l'activité
il ya aussi des passages dans le tunnel
qui sont assez labyrinthique on peut se
perdre
un équipement particulier à posséder
avant de rentrer donc
du coup c'est quand même préférable
d'être accompagné